hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
your host for this week
for the first time in a while and with
me are the boys as usual
and we have a guest introduce yourself
hello podcast listeners and video
viewers
my name is ladybeard i'm thrilled to be
here today
on the trash tape podcast jesus christ
normally we have to like bring the
energy to the gas i feel like i'm being
brought up
no ladies you brought the energy down
honey how i came with all
that's how this started for viewers at
home we had a pre-production meeting in
denny's
and the old lady very generous way of
warding yeah reproduction
it's just a lunch yeah we we ate lunch
at denny's before we did this
and uh the old lady who works at denny's
made a point of coming up to us to tell
us that we were
she made
and there's a guy who just knows the
exact time and like the exact day that
we come here
when we come hurley he's like oh yo
you're a bit earlier than usual yeah
that's great that's fantastic you're
regulars that's wonderful
um are we allowed to am i like to say
the the general area
of japan which the studio was in no no
we're in we're in japan in the same
general area right now um i actually
have a reputation of ruining things for
people because
one of my best friends lives in this
general area too yeah and so it was a
night when
i went uh to his house and um we played
this game
okay i'm scared now
we played this game when we went walking
out it's the middle of summer time we're
about two three in the morning we went
out to do the convenience store and the
things you normally do
and we played this game of you know
there's only certain institutions that
are open of that time
right right right so we made this game
when we would go into the institution
you know
japan they have the little trade to put
your money in when you pay
yeah yeah we made this game out we go
and we you know do whatever buy our
stuff at the convenience store
and then we would flip over the tray and
see how they reacted
because a lot of people in japan people
working the service industry
can't handle that right
it was it was a bit it was it was
probably a bit nasty because my friend
is this huge bodybuilder guy right
so i'm a pro wrestler so we're there and
the dude behind the convenience it's 3
a.m
there's two foreigners there's no other
humans for miles around he's this tiny
little dude
and i'm like but what would you do sir
if i
did this and just wait
he was looking like you're maintaining
icons
he will never talk to a foreigner ever
again anyway but then the game became
you would run into an institution you'd
flip the tray and run out
see what would happen basically just
ding dong dashing yeah well
basically now my friend can't go to
zutaya anymore well because
because he's known as that giant dude
who flips straight over
arnold schwarzenegger he's running with
his
the shirt